mais d'abord c'est l'un des grands axes
de circulation de tours trente mille
véhicules empruntent chaque jour le pont
napoléon
sauf que depuis une semaine ça coince
pour permettre la dernière phase de
travaux de rénovation la circulation ne
se fait plus que dans un sens
alertés par des automobilistes en colère
la métropole fait dans la pédagogie
lucas chopin la dernière phase de
travaux du pont napoléon a débuté il y a
deux semaines
fermant la voie de circulation vers le
centre ville et malgré l'ouverture
temporaire du pont wilson
de nombreux automobilistes perdent
patience ça va être les vents laisse
tous les jours afin que je compte à peu
près 30 minutes de plus pour aller au
travail
on fait des détours déjà le matin puis
on part un peu plus tôt objet de faire
le tour donc pas mal de bouchons et peu
dommage détour oui je descends je
descends par le pont mirabeau si vous
voulez ce que j'ai magique ni en colère
au départ c'est que il avait fermé le
pont le pont de pierre
pourtant à la métropole on l'a sur ces
travaux sont nécessaires
la dernière des trois phases de
rénovation du pont concentrent les
efforts sur l'étanchéité de l'édifice
une façon d'en ralentir le
vieillissement un pont il peut durer
plus de 100 ans
celle est vraiment des travaux pour le
faire durer dans le temps
on est dans une cité où les ponts sont
rares donc il faut les entretenir
il faut les choyer afin qu'ils puissent
avoir l'utilisation normale le plus
longtemps possible
les travaux continueront tout l'été le
pont napoléon sera totalement fermée à
la circulation automobile à partir du 5
juillet sur cette période le pont wilson
lui aussi sera fermée oui des travaux ça
crée forcément des désagréments c'est
c'est logique
maintenant nous faisons le nécessaire
cet été je compte sur la compréhension
nos concitoyens parce que les accès
seront que plus difficile mais c'est
aussi pour ça qu'on réalise
les travaux l'été donc patience
détermination et le chantier se passera
bien le retour à la normale est prévu
début septembre sur le pont napoléon
après trois années de travaux